mein name ist nina schenk um mein thema
heute abend ist das gebrochene corona
versprechen vielleicht erinnern sie sich
noch wie ich am 20 märz 2022 versprach
justizminister marco buschmann das ende
der krone regeln lassen sie uns mal
reinhören
es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
wir wissen ja alle dass dieses
versprechen jetzt nicht so ganz
eingehalten wurde ich würde sogar sagen
gebrochen manche maßnahmen wie die
massen pflicht im zug oder im flugzeug
dagegen ist übrigens die lufthansa heute
sehr dagegen getreten ja die hat mir
immer auch im sommer wurde nicht
abgeschafft und jetzt gelten ja ob neue
maßnahmen welche sich je nach lage
entwicklung sogar noch verschärfen
können obendrein muss man dazu sagen
dass marco buschmann dieses versprechen
ja niemals hätte geben müssen deswegen
auch meine erste frage an herr frank
buschmann warum hat er dieses
versprechen jetzt gegeben und dann
wieder gebrochen also musste erst
brechen aufgrund der gesundheitlichen
lage steht uns wieder ein killervirus
bevor wie ist die lage in deutschland
also ich sage ihnen mal das was die
lungen erstes sagen sowohl die chefs
verbandes analogen kliniken alles doch
niedergelassen lungenärzte es gibt quasi
seit früher keine echten coup fälle mehr
es gibt keine
typischen kurve lungenentzündung mehr
die diese erkrankung ist im schon langem
endemischen zustand mir hat letzte woche
ein lungenfacharzt geschrieben aus
niedersachsen einzugsgebiet
hunderttausend patienten alles geht über
ihn in die krankenhäuser noch die
nachsorge sagt zeit früher hat er keine
kurve lungenentzündung mehr gesehen also
ich weiß nicht was die da in berlin
veranstalten aber kobe 19 ist in den
kliniken nach meinung der lungenärzte
nicht mehr existent also sie würden
jetzt sagen marco buschmann hatte sein
versprechen rück halten kein
gesundheitlich gesehen ja ich setze ich
sage nochmal genau was ich davon halte
ich kann es schon mal voraus nehmen also
das ist unsäglich ja ich weiß nicht was
diese panikmache noch soll kann man nach
einem tritt diskutieren was dann
vielleicht dahinter steckt aber hier
wird komplett übertrieben und
während am anfang wie 19 wirklich auch
zu schweren lungen zu dem geführt hatte
mich in dem ausmaß wie gesagt wurde auch
das war definitiv der fall gibt es diese
erkrankung laut lungenärzte das sagte
thomas voss der präsident stellungen
ärzte der kliniken auch öffentlich gibt
es de facto eigentlich nicht mehr aktiv
gewesen wieder also ich sehe es ein
wenig anders wie nicht anders zu
erwarten also
die schweren verläufe die sehen wir
tatsächlich weniger also an der charité
liegen im moment 100 patienten stationär
ein viertel davon ist intensiv pflicht
ich dass es deutlich weniger als das
haben doch eine lungenentzündung die
haben die haben zum teil auch jungen sie
ist zum teil will es ist ein kleinerer
anteil wie viel gerade die auf den
intensivstationen liegen was mir ganz
wichtig ist der prozentuale anteil der
wäre ganz spannend also wie viel prozent
corona patienten liegen gerade in der
charité auf der intensivstation
es sind etwa 20 bis 25 prozent
derjenigen die stationär aufgenommen
stoppte haben einen positiven test die
sind nicht groß in köln cupid patienten
ja also das sind cupid patienten was wir
vermehrt sehen sind patienten die wegen
anderen erkrankungen aufgenommen werden
und dann auch noch sich herausstellt
dass sie hiv-positiv sind das heißt wir
können nicht sagen dass die 20 patienten
wegen krone auf der
intensiven
erkrankungen jetzt auf der
intensivstation sind das ist deutlich
weniger wir haben keine sag ich mal
überlastungen der intensivstation
mehrweg 20 prozent wegen kubik
lungenentzündung auf intensiv der die
geringe deutlich geringeren anzahl von
patienten die wir wegen kurve jetzt
stationär aufnehmen müssen also
gegenüber sagen wir mal vor einem jahr
oder dem winter ist das deutlich weniger
also die ressourcen durch primär co wird
erkrankte im gesundheitswesen werden
nicht mehr so belastet dass wir hatten
das ja dann einmalig belastet was ist
das in absoluten bezahlen damit man als
bürger mal ein einblick also wie viele
absolute zahlen also wie viele liegen
jetzt im krankenhaus cupid 19 also ich
kann sagen in der charité sind es
derzeit etwa 100 und von vielen
mit einem positiven test ist ein großer
unterschied es sind patienten die
entweder wegen primär einer kuh wird
infektion in die klinik gekommen sind
oder aber auch wegen einer anderen
erkrankung jetzt mit einem schweren ko
witt verlaufen aber herr professor
glaeske damit kann man doch nicht
arbeiten wir müssen doch wissen wie
viele patienten exakt wegen kurve dem
krankenhaus liegen wir wissen wir dass
dies die die wii nicht in der lage ist
dann auch die krankenhausgesellschaft
immer noch nicht sauber zu unterscheiden
haben wir echte kurven fehler oder nur
positive test so kann man kein paar
nämlich management machen ja und wenn
wir die lungenärzte sagen sie sehen
keine cupid lungenentzündungen dann ist
die pandemie vorbei und zwar seit
frühjahr und dann möchte ich auch noch
mal die anfrage von herrn kubicki
erinnern an das gesundheitsministerium
er hat gefragt wie kann es sein dass er
in vier wochen im mai
die täglichen berichte des aks von
insgesamt 1800 covi toten sprachen und
im bericht monatsbericht zum gleichen
zeit haben nur von 98 toten gesprochen
wurde das ist das faktor 20 die antwort
war gewesen weil in dieser statistik
flossen und die ein wo man eben den
impfstatus kannte und die auch symptom
hatten ich bitte sie der impfstatus ist
bekannt die in den altenheimen wird
gehen die teams durch die dokumentieren
dass das heißt die meisten dieser kurve
toten hatten überhaupt keine kowitz
symptome also entschuldigung ich habe
immer ein medizinstudium was anderes
gelernt eine krankheit ist dann einer
krankheit nicht wenn ich sie einfach nur
so ein händler sondern die symptome da
sind so können wir nicht weitermachen
also ich möchte eigentlich das augenmerk
und das ist auch ein thema für das ich
jetzt eingeladen worden bin auf ein
anderes problem denken nämlich longo
geht da kann begleichen das weiß ich
aber aber wenn wir über sage ich mal die
belastung in unserer gesellschaft durch
eine erkrankung sprechen dann muss man
auf der einen seite natürlich sehen wie
die akute gefährdung der patienten ist
und auf der anderen seite was dann die
langzeit vor ich bin ganz froh dass wir
darüber gleich reden werden aber was wir
jetzt gerade machen wollen ist die
politik hat immer gesagt die maßnahmen
sind gerechtfertigt wegen der
überlastung der intensivbetten wegen der
möglichen überlassung der krankenhäuser
dann sie ja ganz klar gesagt das haben
wir im moment nicht eine überlastung
eine überlastung im moment nicht genau
deswegen ist natürlich die frage an die
runde ich mache jetzt auch mal gerne auf
nachdem ich ihnen beiden hier das doppel
gelassen habe ob man hier sehen sie das
denn als bürger also die überlastung
haben bin ich da sind sich die beiden ja
einig die gibt es aktuell nicht warum
also noch die maßnahmen der politik also
erstmal wissen wir jetzt als bürger
fragen würde ich erst mal sagen ich
finde solche zahlen schlachten sehr
unangenehm ja also wenn sie werfen
zahlen im raum sie müssen jetzt auch
zahlen reagieren das ist wie eine art zu
diskutieren also ich bin vater von zwei
kindern ich bin selber co wieder krank
gewesen wenn ich gerne nicht gewesen er
denkt die emotionale basis lieben haben
nicht die emotionale basis sondern
nehmen wir mal ein ding als profit
aufkam war es ein lohnproblem mit
intensiv belastung wenn wir das heute
nicht mehr haben dann würde ich sagen
dann ist das ja nicht notwendigerweise
der grund dafür dass man heute trotzdem
mit maßnahmen reagieren will weil heute
gibt es so themen sie sprechen es ja an
longo wie heute gibt es vielleicht gibt
es ja durch die neuen viren andere
erkrankungen andere situationen deswegen
dann vorsichtsmaßnahmen notwendig sind
also dass sie finden es gut dass die
politik weiter die maßnahmen hat wie
beispielsweise masken pflicht im pflege
heute lufthansa selber das unternehmen
gesagt hat sie wollen das nicht mehr
haben um eine maßnahme er zu nah sie
wird erst mal sagen was der das
flugunternehmen selber gerne hätte oder
nicht hätte kann nicht relevant sein für
die frage wie man schutzmaßnahmen zum
wohl der bevölkerung
die politik weiß alles bei wahrnehmen
würde ich so nicht sagen also flieger
finde ich zb interessantes thema ich bin
selber ja auch gelogen und die flieger
haben ja gute hepa filter drin und das
heißt wer mit dem flugzeug unterwegs ist
es eigentlich sehr gut geschützt dadurch
von die luft durch die zirkulation sehr
gut gehalten und nach die meisten fliegt
beispielsweise im flieger gute frage
doch würde ich auch sagen verstehe ich
jetzt nicht kann man doch eigentlich
erklären ich meine ja irgendwo in den
büros überall werden gerade diese mobil
hepa filter aufgestellt dann wird gesagt
ihr könnt jetzt im büro zusammen ohne
maske sitzen weil ihr habt euch da jetzt
so ein lüfter hingestellt mit hepa
filter drin ja ob ein flieger soll es
dann nicht klappen da verstehe ich dann
noch dass manche sagen das bin ich jetzt
nicht zusammen manche mit der politik
nicht ganz ich würde eher sagen liebe
leute wir haben doch jetzt also ich
suche eigentlich den lernerfolg den
versuche ich jetzt eigentlich zu
verstehen wir haben jetzt ja eine zeit
lang wie gehabt wir haben eine pandemie
gehabt wir haben viele
vorsichtsmaßnahmen gehabt jetzt mit
sicherheit haben die ganze menge leute
studien darüber angefertigt was heraus
gekriegt wie könnte man das besser
machen und wenn dann das maßnahmenpaket
so den geschmack hat na ja wir machen
das noch mal so wie vorher dann frage
ich mich als bürger er ich hätte jetzt
haben eine kommunikation zum lernerfolg
also dass man gemerkt hat wartet mal so
richtig gut gebracht hat das was und
überhaupt nichts gebracht hat das war's
aber wir müssen niemanden gab es ja aber
wir fragen einmal frau blank wie sehen
sie das denn als bürgerin mit dem koma
versprechen was gebrochen wurde also ich
würde sagen jetzt im sommer sich die
masken ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich
effizient weil deshalb derzeit einfach
die zahlen nicht hergeben wenn es im
winter jetzt oder im herbst will den
größeren ausbruch sieht dann kann ich
schon verstehen dass man irgendwie haben
möchte was man im öffentlichen
nahverkehr und im flugzeug und zum
beispiel deutsche bahn eben die masken
trägt damit zum beispiel hier ist nicht
zum notstand kommt in bestimmten
berufssparten dass es zum beispiel zu
wenig der krankenpfleger einem
bestimmten bereich gibt also da sehe ich
dann wirklich als wichtig an aber dann
würde ich dann bald wirklich reagieren
wenn irgendwie die zahlen hochschnellen
und ich einfach generell sagen dass man
immer diese masten und tragen haben sie
persönlich angst vor einem schweren
verlauf sie sind ja unter 30 haben sie
selber angst nee ich persönlich habe
ehrlich gesagt keine angst ich habe
eigentlich als kind eine
lungenentzündung und eigentlich dann zu
dieser risikoklasse aber also ich hab da
selber eine kurve erkrankung im februar
und ich hatte ja eine mandelentzündung
kein husten dabei deshalb mit mandeln zu
nun komme ich gut klar hätte ich jetzt
wussten wer ist eine andere sache
vielleicht darf ich ganz gut was vom
blanken angesprungen hat eingehen dass
ich mich ein ganz wichtiger punkt
personalausfälle also das ist bei uns
schon ein thema und wir haben im moment
krankheitsbedingt personalausfälle in
der klinik an der charité zwischen fünf
und zehn prozent des unterschreitens
bild unterschiedliche berufsgruppe und
ein guter teil davon ist kurve die viele
dürfen nicht mehr arbeiten wegen der
einrichtungs beziehungen pflicht bei
ihnen wenn wir über den pflegenotstand
sprechen das spielt keine rolle warum
spart weil die häuser weil die fast alle
gegen da gibt es welche die bei ihnen
nicht gelingt sind minimalste und die
dürfen wir arbeiten richtig die sind
eigentlich von den am patienten an alle
arbeit am patienten nicht mehr
zugelassen aber wie gesagt bei uns
bilden das keine rolle eine rolle spielt
es für sie keine rolle wenn sie darüber
sprechen dass pfleger man sie braucht
und sie sagen wir haben die sozialen
einigen fehlt das keine rolle was
wirklich eine rolle spielt ist eben der
der ausfall durch kurven erkrankung das
merken wir dass ich das ist das nicht
eine rolle wenn man jetzt schon von
gebrochenen versprechen sprechen ist das
nicht seltsam dass bei ihnen alle
geimpft sein und so viele kurve bekommen
ausfallen was sagt uns das denn die
impfung schützt nicht davor und da
konnte auch noch richtig dass also ich
glaube jedoch entschieden dass es
vielleicht vor dem schweren verlauf aber
nicht komplett davor so essen sie sich
darstellen doch so kann ich darstellen
und bekam gleich noch überleben wir
müssen da die und nach über die zahlen
noch mal sprechen aber weil die zahlen
sind wichtig selbst der bruder von hand
scholz ja als klinikdirektor sagt es ist
ein wahnsinn jemand wegen einer
positiven test nach hause zu schicken
obwohl er gesund ist oder vielleicht die
kernthemen sind diese personalprobleme
entstehen nicht durch coop 19 sondern
mit dem umgang damit ist ein großer
unterschied also das ist ein völliges
märchen das kogit 19 zu
personalengpässen führt durch das virus
selbst ist es der umgang damit er in der
frank der keine symptome zeigen kann wie
auch früher arbeiten ich bin dafür dass
man diesen test
verwendet so für das was er gemacht ist
wenn ich in der differentialdiagnose
brauche bei symptomen bei schwerkranken
menschen ob derjenigen vielleicht sonst
ask of 2 erkrankt ist dann ist dieser
test sinnvoll diesen test an symptomen
losen menschen einzusetzen ist
kompletter humbug das ist international
so klar wird dass gesehen aber wir
deutschen machen einfach immer weiter
wenn wir da den wanderweg also ich weiß
nicht ob das ein sonderweg ist ich
möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
wir natürlich in der klinik umgehen mit
hochrisiko menschen die kommen weil sie
schwer krank sind und wenn wir die jetzt
auch noch in der klinik anstecken und
wir haben ja solche situationen auch wir
sehen das ja dann bringen wir die in
eine ganz besondere gefahrenlage
deswegen glaube ich schon dass es
gerechtfertigt ist dass man hier ein
besonderes augenmerk darauf legt dass
die patientinnen und patienten die sich
in behandlung begeben
so gut es geht da vorgeschlagen werden
masken getragen riecht und während
manche leute sind weil sie immer gesagt
die anderen dürfen hier nicht mehr
zählen und dann haben sie so einen hohen
krankheitsstand was bringen die
maßnahmen denn dann also noch einmal
das wollte ich eigentlich immer noch mal
an der hörn kollegen frank sagen die
impfung hat uns wahnsinnig weiter
gebracht weil sie und das haben wir
gerade mit dem intensiv zahlen ja auch
gesehen weil sie eben die schweren
krankheitsverläufe
massiv reduziert andere sagen dass der
im test die dass der virus einfach
leichter wurde und mutiert ist und
dementsprechend auch weniger als 1 stand
gehalten werden dies nicht kommentieren
was andere sagen sondern ich will
kommentieren was die wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse über die ergebnisse der
impfungen sagen und die impfung und das
haben sie ganz richtig gesagt reduziert
das risiko auch an kurve zu erkranken
aber er schließt eine kurve infektion
nicht aus das muss man auch mal ganz
klar sagen so dass es möglich ist dass
ich heute trotz dreifacher impfungen
eine kurve die infektion bekommen
positiv werde vielleicht minimale
symptome habe und das ist ja glaube ich
auch er ihr argument oder auch ein
bisschen mehr symptome habe symptome wie
bei einem grippalen infekt aber ich bin
während diesem zeitpunkt infektiös für
andere das muss man mal ganz klar sagen
und wenn ich jemand anstecke der ein
hochrisiko patienten oder mensch ist
dann bringe ich den vielleicht in große
krise schließen sowie sowieso schließen
sie dann und schließen sie dann
ungeimpfte aus wendige impften mit
kurven symptomen dann ein problem für
die kranken sind ich verstehe das nicht
ich verstehe diese logik nicht
noch mal was meinen sie haben gerade
gilt von geimpften mitarbeitern
gesprochen die wenn sie einen positiven
test haben wir dann eine gefahr sind für
die kranken ja wie das ist doch das
argument dass sie die umgebung schon
ausschließen die ungeimpften sie noch
eine gefahr für die kranken gezogen sie
die geimpften sind eine gefahr für die
kranken also irgendwie ist das alles
also glaubt pärchen an der ist nicht
wirklich geht also eher frankfurt
komplett durcheinander ist da gar nicht
herr frank man wahrscheinlich dass man
sich ja auch bei der impfung anstecken
kann auch patienten anstecken kann wenn
man geimpft
wir haben eine einen zugriff wir haben
eine einrichtung bezogene im pflichtteil
verlieren eben 60 jährige altenpflegerin
ihren job die werden rausgeschmissen
wenn sie einfach aus gutem grund sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen weil sie
angeblich eine gefahr für die kranken
sind und gerade haben sie gesagt die
geimpften sind dann eine gefahr für die
kranken deswegen muss ich sie testen
also das ist das kann ich nachvollziehen
also ich kann es gut nachvollziehen sie
können auch viele menschen gut
nachvollziehen wenn die die impfung
schützt nicht vor der erkrankung wenn
ich erkrankt bin in der akutphase bin
ich hoch infektiös kann andere anstecken
das ist das entscheidende kriterium das
ein infektiöser mensch nicht an einen
anderen hochinfektiösen anderen menschen
hochrisiko anderen menschen also
patienten in unserem kontext heran gehen
darf und sie müssen sich ja vorstellen
die pflegekräfte aber auch die ärzte und
so weiter wir arbeiten ja zum teil ganz
nah am patienten ich glaube wir müssen
gerade so weiter um geld eigentlich
immer wieder solche spieler sehr these
wir sind ich glaube wir gehen jetzt
einmal weiter nochmal zu den tieren sind
ja nicht mediziner oder wenn sie sagen
dass da wenn so nicht sagen das kann ich
sagen ich finde es erstmal
unverantwortlich aus arbeitgeber also
ich bin selber arbeitgeber gewesen man
darf die arbeitsschutz interessen das
individuellen mitarbeiters nicht einfach
so schlicht außen macht außer acht lasse
das passiert ja bei der einrichtung
aktion eine vielleicht endlich mal
krankenhäuser raus ich bin jetzt mal
ganz normaler arbeitgeber ich habe
irgendwie meinetwegen eine firma und der
arbeiten der 200 mitarbeiter drin
jetzt kann ich nicht alle dazu bringen
zu sagen legt man euren
gesundheitsstatus offen welche habt ihr
irgendwelche schwierigen risiko
erkrankungen weil das feld alles unter
daten der gesundheitsstatus musste
offengelegt werden bei der mine also
kommt es verstehe mich gerade also wenn
jetzt zum beispiel ich habe diabetes ich
hab's orie asus das sage ich so bin ich
jetzt bei einem arbeitgeber wäre und die
wäre der arbeitnehmer dann hätte ich ein
recht darauf dass für mich zu behalten
ich habe aber als mitarbeiter in einer
firma haupt ein recht darauf dass mein
dass der vorgesetzte sorge trägt dafür
dass ich nicht an meinem arbeitsplatz
einem ja ich sag mal erkrankungsrisiko
ausgesetzt bin dh der arbeitgeber eine
arbeitsschutz pflicht wir machen jetzt
ein ganz neues thema auf das würde ich
jetzt gerne verschiedene spät ja es ist
nicht ganz neu sondern man kann nicht
alles auch so sagen nach dem motto man
sollte leute einfach überall rum laufen
lassen ohne maske ohne alles wenn sie
jemand anders anstecken können wir da
müssen wir fragen wie kann man das
sicher stellen dass man weiß ob jemand
ansteckungsfähigkeit also ob er einig ob
er den virus in sich trainer wenig